c'est une première en France ce n'est ni
un foyer ni une structure médicale mais
une résidence 16 studios avec partie
commune louée à des personnes autistes
adultes elles gardent ainsi leur
indépendance même si elles sont
accompagnées au quotidien par des
professionnels formés le début d'une
nouvelle vie et la chapelet
après plusieurs jours passés chez ses
parents et ma est de retour dans son
studio à avoine la jeune femme de 23 ans
vit seule dans cette résidence un peu
particulière ici les 16 logements ont
été pensés pour accueillir des adultes
autistes autonomes après plusieurs
années passées dans un foyer de vie avec
des personnes qui souffraient de divers
handicaps depuis le mois de juin Emma et
locataire de cet appartement un lieu à
elle avec sa décoration
j'aime bien rester parce que je fais des
activités mieux que là où j'étais avant
je me sens bien
je me sens à l'aise
et je me fais des copains c'est un peu
comme à la maison la cuisine le salon
qui partage c'est très très chaleureux
elle commence vraiment à bien se
s'habituer au rythme et à se sentir chez
elle
pendant que la jeune femme se rend à son
rendez-vous avec l'orthophoniste non
loin de là on bricole Dylan continue une
création en mosaïque dans une pièce
commune de la résidence une activité qui
n'est pas seulement occupationnelle mais
qui fait également travailler sa
motricité et la notion de morcellement
tous les jours de la semaine des
animations non obligatoires sont
proposées par Franck et Xavier un
animateur spécialisé dans l'autisme il
fait partie de la quinzaine de salariés
qui se relaient sur place nuit et jour
pour accompagner les locataires
par exemple il faut les accompagner pour
faire la toilette au moins par la parole
il faut
leur les aider les accompagner pour
faire les courses pour faire à manger
pour etc donc ils ont besoin d'un
accompagnement et c'est là qu'intervient
effectivement l'association d'aide à
domicile ADMR